Вітаю! З вами я, Олена Соляник,
викладач біології школи «Майбутні».
І сьогодні ми з 9 класом
у курсі «Еволюція»
розглянемо тему: «Еволюція людини».
Взагалі тема «Еволюція людини» -
це, мабуть, найцікавіше, що
є у всьому курсі «Еволюція».
Мабуть, цікавіше за еволюцію
людини лише тема «Походження життя».
Але з цим ми розберемося трохи згодом.
А тема «Еволюція людини» і тема
«Походження людини» вона торкає кожного.
Навколо цієї теми дуже багато,
так скажімо, навколо наукових
і зовсім ненаукових фактів і
наша найперша задачу розібратися,
що зі всієї інформації
має якесь підґрунтя,
що взагалі не відноситься до науки.
Ну, перші думки щодо походження людини
і спільного походження
людини від тваринних предків,
вони існували вже доволі
давно і навіть ті еволюціоністи,
які припускали, що людина
це вище якесь створіння,
яке створене окремо
від усього живого світу,
навіть вони припускали, і
навіть вони погоджувалися з тим,
що є деякі риси подібності між
людиною та певними групами тварин.
Зокрема йдеться про приматів насамперед.
Чарльза Дарвіна дуже часто критикують
за фразу: «людина пішла від мавпи».
Насправді цих слів він не
говорив, він підкреслював
ймовірне походження людини
від спільного з приматами предка.
Тут ось ключове є від
мавпи та від спільного предка
і зараз з цією тезою
ми будемо розбиратися,
тому, насправді, це є ключовим питанням.
Оскільки зараз, наприклад, дуже
багато таких критиків еволюційної теорії,
які виказують думки, що
ось ми подібні до шимпанзе.
А ми, дійсно, подібні до шимпанзе.
Подібність ДНК людини і
шимпанзе складає понад 98 відсотків,
майже 99 відсотків загальної
ДНК у людини і шимпанзе.
Але це зовсім не вказує про
те, що ми пішли від шимпанзе.
Ну і зараз давайте трошки
з цією думкою попрацюємо
і спробуємо з'ясувати, що
ж насправді відбувалося.
Ну, ще Чарльзу Дарвіну дуже
важко було відповідати на це питання
щодо походження людини, хоча в
нього була відповідна праця з цієї теми.
Чому? Тому що за часів Дарвіна
насправді не було достатньої
кількості викопних решток.
Дарвіну були відомі рештки дріопітека.
Дріопітек - це був невеличкий
примат, який жив у саванах Африки
і то насправді було
найближче, що йому відомо.
Зараз ми маємо набагато
більше палеонтологічних даних,
набагато більше матеріалу і
можемо відтворити ланцюг,
яким же чином відбувалися
ці еволюційні перетворення.
То хто ж насправді наш предок?
І до чого тут мавпи і хто,
дійсно, від кого походить?
Давайте зображати це
у вигляді ось такої схеми.
Людина як і людиноподібні
мавпи належать до групи гомінід.
Група гомінід - це дуже древня група,
вона утворилися багато
мільйонів років тому назад,
це спільна група від якої пішла і людина,
і людиноподібні мавпи,
але шляхи ці були різні.
Тож перша група – гомініди.
Якщо ми розглядаємо еволюцію людини,
то від гомінід приблизно 7
мільйонів років тому назад
відокремлюється група австралопітеків.
Австралопітеків багато
видів, це не один вид.
Жили вони довго. Найраніші австралопітеки
жили приблизно 7 мільйонів років тому,
пізні австралопітеки жили
приблизно 4 мільйонів років тому,
тобто бачите протягом 3 мільйонів років
австралопітеки утворили багато
груп, які теж якось змінювалися.
Ми не будемо зараз роздивлятися
усі групи австралопітеків,
наразі ці групи ще встановлюються,
щороку якісь нові рештки
знаходять у різних частинах світу
і тому вся ця картинка дуже
динамічна і буде змінюватися щороку.
Але австралопітек ще не є людиною,
тобто рід не Hоmo, як у нас з вами,
і ми відносимо до виду Ноmo
sapiens (людина розумна).
Австралопітеки відносяться до
іншого роду - австралопітекус.
Все це відбувається у
Африці і там знайдені
доволі багаточисленні рештки цих особин.
І від однієї з груп австралопітеків,
приблизно 3 мільйони років тому назад,
відокремлюються перші - рід
Homo habilis (людина вміла).
Чому відбулося відокремлення
від австралопітеків?
Тому що ця (людина вміла) могла
вже робити найпростіші знаряддя праці.
Це була невеличка істота і ця істота Homo
habilis вже перейшла до життя у саванах.
Перш ніж ми продовжимо
розглядати, що відбувалося
у древніх африканських саванах,
треба з'ясувати ще одне питання.
Ті австралопітеки, ті Hоmo - якими
вони були, як вони пересувалися
і перш за все треба з'ясувати, коли
виникло прямоходіння, яке властиве людям.
Австралопітеки африканські
вже були прямоходячими.
Є кілька теорій, яким же
чином виникло прямоходіння?
Ще кілька років панували теорії
щодо того, що прямоходіння
виникло у зв'язку з
переходом до життя в саванах,
коли площа лісів скоротилася і ці
істоти змушені були жити у саванах.
У саванах було легше
ховатися від хижаків,
коли австралопітеки мали
змогу виглядати, де там ті хижаки.
Для цього треба було
підніматися на задні кінцівки
і таким чином вони поступово
стали прямоходячими.
Але подальші дослідження
цю теорію мало підтверджують.
Решта гомінід, які жили
ще в лісі, ще на деревах,
імовірніше вже були прямоходячими.
Навіщо прямоходіння в лісі?
Насправді це дуже зручно,
коли пересуваєшся гілками
у пошуках фруктів і задніми
кінцівками спираєшся на нижні гілки,
а верхніми кінцівками, тобто руками,
перебираєш і спираєшся на верхні гілки.
Ось ця теорія, яка описує
розвиток прямоходіння у лісі,
вона зараз має найбільшу
кількість прихильників,
тобто ті австралопітеки,
які ще не були людьми,
вони вже могли ходити на
двох кінцівках замість чотирьох.
Ці австралопітеки, що ж вони
там робили в Африці в цій савані?
Вони були ймовірніше падальники.
Вони не могли бути хижаками,
тому що вони не могли
конкурувати з такими, як котячі,
вони не могли активно
полювати, тому що не було чим,
і вони, звісно, не
могли бути травоїдними.
Тому що будова організму, будова
ротового апарату вказує на те,
що вони були всеїдними, тобто імовірніше
наші далекі предки
харчувалися мертвечиною.
Homo habilis був виокремлений
від австралопітеків завдяки тому,
що він вже використовував
простіші знаряддя праці.
Що це були за знаряддя праці? Це були
імовірніше якісь дерев'яні знаряддя праці
і були найпростіші кам'яні
відщепи, які вони використовували
мабуть для того, щоб відшкрібати
залишки м'яса з кісток якихось тварин.
Далі відбувається еволюція вже
роду Homo із першого представника
Homo habilis, тобто людина вміла.
Homo habilis (людина
вміла) згодом еволюціонує
у рід Homo ergaster (людина працьовита).
Ця людина удосконалює знаряддя праці,
ці знаряддя праці також
здебільшого були кам'яні,
ну дерев'яні імовірніше теж були,
але вони не збереглися до наших часів,
а ось кам'яні відщепи
тих часів збереглися.
Наступна стадія еволюції - це Homo
erectus, тобто людина прямоходяча.
Ця людина прямоходяча вона
вже імовірніше використовувала
не лише знаряддя праці, а ще йдуть
суперечки щодо того хто перший -
чи то Homo ergaster, чи то Homo erectus,
але ця людина вже оволоділа вогнем.
Тобто вона могла кулінарно
обробляти якимось чином свою їжу.
Звісно, що кулінарно оброблена
їжа більш доступна для організму,
більш калорійна, тому
ці особини більші на зріст,
у них більший об'єм головного мозку
і вони взагалі є більш досконалішими
ніж попередні особини роду Homo.
Звісно, що тут я
намалювала пряму лінійку,
вона у реаліях прямою
такою і красивою не була,
тут на кожній стадії
були якісь групи особин,
які далі не еволюціонували і
вимирали, але решки їх ми знаходимо.
І ось Homo erectus (людина
прямоходяча) він розповсюдився
усією територією Африки і
відбувається перший вихід
первісних людей до Європи, до Азії.
Вони розповсюджуються і, звісно,
це не був цілеспрямований рух,
тобто древня людина ніяк собі не
думала, що давай я піду в Європу –
звичайно, ні. Вони просто
мігрували за тваринами,
на яких вони вчилися полювати,
вони мігрували за здобиччю
і переносили свої стоянки,
мігруючи тими екосистемами,
якими зручніше було знаходити їжу
або якісь помешкання собі влаштовувати -
чи то у печерах, чи то
у якихось вже спорудах.
Homo erectus (людина прямоходяча)
розповсюджується Азією,
доходить навіть до
території сучасного Китаю,
але в цей час клімат стає холоднішим і
таке активне поширенням припиняється,
і цей суцільний ареал Homo
erectus розбивається на кілька груп,
які лишаються на довгий час
еволюціонувати самі по собі.
Ось, наприклад, на території
Азії утворилися синантропи,
на територію сучасної Грузії утворюється,
так звана, людина грузинська, тощо.
Коли кліматичні умови знову
стають більш сприятливими,
а це відбувається вже через
кілька десятків тисяч років,
утворюється новий вид людини
- це людина гейдельберзька.
Щодо походження людини гейдельберзької
також немає єдиного
погляду де це відбулося,
тому що є рештки людини
гейдельберзької європейської,
людини гейдельберзької азійської і
людини гейдельберзької африканської.
Але більшість дослідників
все ж таки сходяться на тому,
що це відбулося, знову ж таки, у Африці.
Наступна стадія - це
людина гейдельберзька.
Ось ця людина гейдельберзька вона
дає початок двом спорідненим групам:
безпосередньо, від людини
гейдельберзької походять неандертальці
і, безпосередньо, від
людини гейдельберзької,
нарешті, походить наш
з вами вид Homo sapiens.
Тобто неандертальці не є нашими предками,
а є нашими, ну так би
мовити, еволюційними братами.
Коли це все відбувається?
Утворення відокремлення виду Homo sapiens
починається приблизно
200 тисяч років тому.
Звідки ми це знаємо?
Ну, по-перше, є викопні
рештки, які ми можемо датувати,
тобто встановити їх
вік. Ці рештки знаходять,
деякі більш масові, деякі менш масові,
наприклад, рештки різноманітних
австралопітеків знайдено дуже багато,
рештки неандертальців
знайдено дуже багато.
Деякі інші види представлені
якимись одиничним знахідками
або навіть єдиною кісткою.
І ось тут я хочу розказати
вам дуже цікаву історію про те,
як був відкритий новий вид
людини Денисової печери.
Я згадала на попередньому слайді,
але не розповіла про цю людину.
Це знахідка дуже цікава.
На Алтаї є так звана Денисова печера.
Чим вона унікальна?
Вона унікальна тим, що там
створені такі умови мікроклімату,
температура, вологість і породи,
які відкладаються пошарово
і рештки, які там накопичилися,
вони залишилися в дуже гарному стані.
Розкопуючи ці шари, шар
за шаром, можна прослідити,
що в цій печері жили первісні
люди і ось її активно досліджують
і шар за шаром піднімають і вивчають
цю історію, яким чином це відбувалося.
Ось однією з решток була
фаланга мізинця, ще й дитини,
тобто це була одна маленька кісточка.
Але вона зберіглася напрочуд
добре і була така думка,
а чи не зберіглася ДНК в цій кісточці?
І цю кісточку віддали на дослідження.
Частину відправили до
Франції, частину - до Німеччини,
виділили ДНК і ось
коли прочитали оцю ДНК,
то з'ясувалося, що ми маємо
справу з окремим видом.
Тобто ця ДНК відмінна від ДНК
людини розумної, ця ДНК відмінна
від ДНК неандертальця, тобто
це є взагалі новий вид людини.
І ось цю людину назвали -
людина Денисової печери,
тобто новий вид був відкритий взагалі
з єдиної знахідки, з єдиної кісточки.
Тобто ви бачите, яким чином
сучасні методи молекулярної біології,
дійсно, допомагають нам розкрити
історію, яким чином все відбувалося.
Ось приблизно таким чином
це відбувалося або навіть звідси.
Деякі дослідники виводять цю людину.
Це людина Денисової печери,
або ще цих людей називают "денисівці".
Ось приблизно 30 тисяч років
тому всі ці три групи людей:
людина Homo sapiens, неандерталець
та людина Денисової печери
жили на певних територіях разом.
І навіть, знову ж таки, нам
допомогла генетика з’ясувати те,
що деякі з них схрещувалися між собою.
Таким чином в деяких людських
популяціях в нас є неандертальські гени.
В нашому геномі людини приблизно
4 відсотків неандертальських генів,
тобто ми схрещувалися з неандертальцями
вільно і було плодюче потомство.
Деякі людські популяції схрещували
із людьми Денисової печери
і також у деяких людських
популяціях є ці гени денисівців.
Також знайдена велика кількість
стоянок та поселень цієї первісної людини,
стоянки та поселення знайдені
всюди: на території Африки,
і на території Європи, і на території
Азії, деякі з них в більш гарному стані,
деякі з них в менш гарному стані.
Поселення кам'яного віку
знайдені навіть на території України.
Тобто це не рідкісне явище і цим
зараз займаються антропологи масово.
Також знайдені знаряддя праці,
побутові речі і навіть прикраси.
Людина гейдельберзька вже
володіла добре знаряддями праці,
добре володіла вогнем будувала житло.
Неандертальці - деякі дослідники вказують
на те, що у них була розвинена мова.
Як вони це могли з'ясувати?
Вони це могли з'ясувати
завдяки вивченню будови кісток,
насамперед кісток голови, кісток черепа.
Можна вивчаючи кістки,
визначити місця прикріплення м'язів,
а ми знаємо, які м'язи
прикріплюються до яких кісток,
тобто ми можемо визначити
наскільки розвиненими були ці м'язи.
І от вивчаючи неандертальців,
навіть припускають, що
вони вже володіли мовою.
У неандертальців була розвинена
культура, вони використовували одяг,
вони використовували ритуали.
Є викопні поховання неандертальців,
у яких окрім, власне, кісток самих
неандертальців, знаходять елементи одягу,
елементи якихось речей
побутових, прикраси.
Тобто неандертальці не
просто кидали своїх померлих,
а у них існували ритуали поховання.
І доволі довгий час Людина
розумна співіснувала
з цими двома групами первісних людей.
Але врешті-решт Людина
розумна, а саме кроманьйонці,
тобто ми з вами кроманьйонці,
вони витіснили неандертальців.
Завдяки чому? Тут суперечки також
дуже активні щодо цього приводу точаться.
Деякі дослідники припускають,
що кроманьйонці були хитріші
або використовували більш
досконалі знаряддя полювання.
Наприклад, неандертальці
були фізично більш сильними,
більш кремезними, але ті
шпилі, які вони використовували,
вони їх не кидали вони ними
користувалися контактно,
а кроманьйонці ті шпилі, які
знаходять у поселеннях кроманьйонців,
вони більш легкі і це наводить на думку,
що кроманьйонці вміли їх кидати і кидати
доволі точно і доволі на далекі відстані.
Можливо, це було причиною,
можливо, щось інше.
Ми поки що не знаємо, ми це вивчаємо.
Маємо врешті-решт єдиний вид
на планеті Земля - Ноmo sapiens,
який розповсюдився усієї територію
нашої планети і утворив раси.
Раси - це скоріше екологічні
групи, тобто групи людей,
які пристосовані до певних
екологічних умов довкілля.
Люди усіх рас вільно схрещуються
між собою і здатні давати здорове,
родюче потомство. Ось така історія
про розвиток роду Homo sapiens
і у мене для вас є невеличке
питаннячко на засипку, як-то кажуть,
для домашнього завдання.
Первісна людина була темношкірою,
була темноволосою і була
кароокою - це доведений факт.
З чим можна пов'язати
виникнення різних рас,
які, як ви знаєте,
відрізняються і кольором очей,
і кольором волосся, і кольором шкіри.
Подумайте над цим, будь ласка,
а відповідь на це питання ми
розберемо на початку наступного року.
На сьогодні наше заняття вже
завершено. Дякую вам за увагу.
Подумайте над домашнім
завданням. Побачимось!